[Musique]
j'suis conne
il vous
peut être le chauffeur livreur est alors
de deux mois les grandes villes du monde
écoutez ça l'un des choix tempête
paraissent embrasser la peur du tout et
les yeux je ne veux donner
[Rires]
[Musique]
oui
certains serveurs et lui c'est le
mangeur plus connu à part donc plus mona
[Musique]
est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour on
aurait une tablée des chefs
c'est ma place après 20 minutes 2011
ouais
[Musique]
oh
de si bon matin je partage ma vue
regardez c'est pas mal quand même
aujourd'hui ces conférences de presse
rend cinq cultures
et les lieux et alors je prends le taxi
avec qui je tombe bien sûr à temps mais
comment sa seconde dans le même taxi
match contre je comprends pas parce que
je vais commander un taxi
et puis je suis rentré dedans par la
même occasion ouais enfin au même
endroit au même endroit et il semble en
fait tous les toute la magie il doit y
avoir en main quelque part
[Musique]
mais les choses
vous
les gars on se retrouve avec des choeurs
entonner oui avec maxime gainey s'est
elle affiche au contraire on se retrouve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le champ centre en jeu
je le sens
je
[Musique]